just a bit of breaking news we can bring  you from Manchester magistrates court  regarding this guy he is Ismail abedi  now he's the brother of the Manchester  Arena bomber uh an arrest warrant has  now been issued at Manchester  magistrates court for uh Ismail abedi  he's failed to appear at the Manchester  Arena attack they want to talk to him  about what he knew and see if any  lessons can be learned as part of this  wide-ranging public inquiry and to that  end an arrest board has now been issued  by Manchester magistrates court for him  to appear it is not known where he is  there isn't speculation that he could  have fled possibly to Turkey but Ismail  a baby an arrest warrant now issued by  Manchester magistrates convicted for  failing to appear at the Manchester  Arena inquiry